oh wow look at this
[Music]
I got told in church many times that
like there's really no hope you found
the black girl you know I'm adopted
I was calling like pretty often like by
my cousins like really often they were
all white like they would always degrade
me and not include me and stuff
like I know there's like I watch other
black people and I see stuff that
they're doing and it's like it's totally
me so that's like something that I hope
to discover and
hopefully become like an empowering
black woman
I've never been to an ocean my heart's
racing a little bit but I feel like I
could fly right now
my heart starts racing because I've
Never Been Kissed before
[Music]
oh here I got something to show you
Rebecca James will you marry me
foreign
I just need my mom if I would live with
Hajj my family would never talk to me
again and I need them if your family
really loved you they would love you no
matter what it would be um
can fish no they do love me
see the reason they shunned me is
because they love me it's very common
for Amish people to have their teeth
pulled at a young age
so there's my teeth
tell I ever been in
Amish we don't go out to eat except at
somebody else's house or at wedding
but it would be much better if I'd have
something to put in it
I'd always keep something on me in case
my lady gets thirsty
[Music]
okay good good thank you
foreign
[Music]
Yeshiva
killed Larry hittlebell while he was
sleeping
so let me get this straight my
mother cheated
on you
with her sister's husband
[Music]
thank you